a sequel to the Assassin's Creed movie
is already in the works
that's according to Entertainment site
the tracking board who report that film
studio New Regency is already set to
move forward with the sequel to the
movie about stabbing people throughout
history you know the one that doesn't
come out until December the report
indicates that Michael Fassbender has
also signed on to be a part of the
sequel after starring in the first film
we'd first heard rumors that there would
be a sequel back in July of last year
the tracking board reported that the
studio's interest in the sequel could be
interpreted as a sign of confidence from
those involved in the success of the
first film Ubisoft has also previously
said that the absence of a mainline
Assassin's Creed game this year will
lend more space and opportunity to
promote the film Assassin's Creed is due
out on December 21st
EB soft is no stranger to making films
out of their games as they're also
working on movies based on their far cry
Rabbids watchdogs Splinter Cell and
Ghost Recon franchises let me know what
your expectations are for this one and
for all the latest in gaming stay tuned
to games web